Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today, I’m
going to explain a science fiction action
film called “District 9.” Spoilers
ahead! Watch out and take care!
The film opens with a documentary-style series
of interviews that introduce the story. Twenty
years ago, in 1982, a giant extraterrestrial
spaceship had arrived above Johannesburg, South
Africa. Humankind was shocked, because it was the
first instance of an alien species visiting them.
However, as the humans waited for aliens to
come out, the ship hovered over the city for
three months with no sign of life. Eventually,
humans took the initiative and cut into the
ship to investigate what was inside. They were
surprised to have discovered a large group of
aliens who were malnourished and sick. More than
a million aliens were given permission to leave
their craft and live on Earth. The government of
South Africa relocated them to a terrestrial camp
for their safety. They were housed in a squalid
government camp in Johannesburg, consisting
mostly of rusty-looking one to two-room shacks.
However, over the years, the camp turned into a
slum because of overcrowding and militarization.
Currently, the place is known as ‘district 9’.
It is now twenty years later since the ship
landed, and the aliens have repopulated into 1.8
million of them. They cannot go back to their
planet, because during the landing, a command
module had fallen into the earth’s surface and
was never found; hence, the giant extraterrestrial
spaceship is still hovering above the city, but
is inoperable. Stuck in the slum for two decades,
the aliens have formulated their own lifestyle.
They started to ransack the nearest pile of
garbage for food. The aliens had no sense of
ownership, so they burned and destroyed cars and
other human properties. On top of that, the slum
was heavily armed, as a Nigerian black market sold
human weapons to aliens at a high price. A massive
black market is set up between the aliens and a
Nigerian gang of criminals led by a half-paralyzed
psychopathic man named Obesandjo. Obesandjo’s gang
sold to them canned cat food, which happens to be
liked by the aliens. In addition, inter-species
prostitution was also encouraged.
The aliens have learned to speak and
understand English, and are good
at communicating with humans.
However, they do not possess any leadership
qualities or functions. It is later assumed
that a plague may have wiped out all of the
leadership-caste. Soon the Nigerians start to
get fed up with the aliens. After twenty years,
they have put up signs in the park and shops,
banning them from entering. A derogatory term
“prawn” comes into fashion, referring to the
bottom-feeding sea creature they resemble. Humans
begin to riot and protest, to remove the Prawns
from Johannesburg. The locals begin to complain
that the government is wasting too much money
on this filthy creature. The aliens are being
called ignorant lawbreakers, who bleed resources
from humans. Patience over the alien situation
among the people of Johannesburg has run out.
Following the dispute between the aliens and
locals, the government hires Multinational United
(MNU), a private weapons manufacturer company,
that shows little regard for the aliens' welfare.
The aliens also have weaponry of their own,
which are engineered in a biological manner,
making them unusable for humans. The MNU
does research on such alien ammunition.
The MNU is tasked to relocate the aliens from
District 9 to a new camp outside the city.
An MNU field operative named Wikus van der
Merwe, is made the commander of the mission.
Wikus and a team of soldiers are sent
to district 9 to make the Prawns sign a
contract of evacuation. With his assistant, and a
soldier, Wikus goes house to house in district 9.
They also shoot and kill some of the
uncooperative aliens. Then, they come across
a house with alien eggs, and set it on fire.
Meanwhile, three aliens, Christopher Johnson,
his young son CJ, and Christopher's friend, search
a garbage dump for alien fuel in Prawn technology.
Christopher has been working to synthesize a
liquid for the past twenty years and is finally
successful. However, just then, Wikus and his team
arrive at his front door. Christopher’s friend
goes to see Wikus, as Christopher hides the liquid
in the house and runs away through the back door.
Wikus and his team go inside the house to
search for weapons, where they find the liquid.
While inspecting it, Wikus accidentally sprays
it on his face. After composing himself, he puts
the liquid in a bag to send it to the lab later.
Christopher’s friend starts to attack Wikus, so
his team is shot dead by the soldiers. Wikus’s arm
is injured in the fight, so his assistant dresses
it. Soon he starts feeling uncomfortable and sick.
He vomits while inspecting Christopher’s home.
His team takes him to a nearby restaurant
where his nose secretes a black fluid.
They start worrying for him, and take
him back to the MNU headquarters.
Wikus cannot stop coughing and feels dizzy; his
fingernails start to decay and fall off. Back at
District 9, Christopher and his son desperately
search for the liquid they had hidden.
That day, Wikus comes home to a surprise party.
As he is about to cut the cake, he vomits black
substance all over it. The guests are disgusted.
His wife takes him to the doctor. He undoes the
dressing from his arms, and is horrified
to see it has changed into an alien claw.
Wikus panics and starts yelling, as the doctor
tries to calm him down. The doctor then calls
the security and restrains Wiskus. They put
him in a body bag and take him to the MNU lab.
They find out that he is turning into an alien
because of the liquid that was splashed onto
his face that day. They also find the liquid
in his pocket. The doctors perform several
experiments on him. It turns out that Wiskus
can use the alien weapon that no humans can.
They even make him shoot an innocent
prawn, as he begs them to leave the guy.
The scientists discover that his DNA is
currently "in balance" with the alien DNA,
which is gradually transforming him completely
into a prawn. With the permission of Wikus'
ruthless father-in-law, they decide to harvest
his body for biological material at this critical
point, and sell them to the organizations and
governments who are keen on biotechnology.
However, as they are about to perform the
procedures on him, he manages to break free
and overpower his captors. He then flees from
the MNU headquarters and ends up in his home.
But the MNU agents are already there looking for
him. He goes to a nearby restaurant where he sees
himself on the news. It is falsely reported that
he has had prolonged sexual intercourse with a
prawn, making him turn into one of them. The news
also claims that his disease is contagious, and
warns people to stay twenty feet away if they come
across him. With nowhere to go, he takes refuge in
District 9. Wikus ends up in Christopher’s shed,
where he finds that Christopher has hidden the
spaceship’s command module that had disappeared
years ago. The liquid he prepared was the fuel to
activate the ship again so they could go back
to their planet. The same fuel can help Wikus
turn back to humans. So, the two prepare to go to
the MNU headquarters to bring back the liquid.
Wikus goes to the gang leader, Obesandjo,
to buy some weapons for their quest.
However, Obesandjo wants to cut off Wikus’s
alien arm to eat it. The Nigeriens believe
that eating alien body parts will get rid of
diseases according to a concept called Muti.
Before they can cut his arms, Wikus gets his
hands on an alien weapon and attacks the gang.
With the help of it, he collects all other weapons
and flees from there. Christopher and Wikus then
attack the MNU headquarters. Because of the
weapons, they manage to wipe out most of the
lab within minutes. The Colonel who is in charge
of MNU’s security and has been tasked to capture
Wikus, arrives with his squad. Wikus finally finds
the liquid; but just then, Christopher finds his
fellow alien in the lab. He had been experimented
upon by humans. The soldiers get inside the lab
and start firing at them. The two beak the walls
and manage to flee from there. However, the police
chopper follows their car to district 9.
Christopher and Wikus are now in his shed,
where Christopher reveals that he has to save his
people first, only then he will transform Wikus.
Agitated, Wikus hits him with a log and knocks
him out. He then powers up the ship himself. Wikus
gets in it and flies the ship while the whole
world watches in awe. However, when the craft
is midair, it is knocked out by an MNU missile.
The soldiers arrest Wikus from inside the ship,
while Christopher’s son, CJ hides. Just then, the
soldiers are attacked by Obesandjo and his men.
After an intense fight between them, Wikus is
captured by Obesandjo. Obesandjo is about to
cut off Wikus’s arm to eat it, but is stopped when
little CJ activates an automated gun and fires at
them. As Wikus escapes, the mother ship that had
been dormant for all these years starts moving.
Wikus then gets to the huge automated
battle suit and starts controlling it.
He initially plans to run away using it,
but then comes back to rescue Christopher.
The two start running towards the spacecraft, but
the battle suit is shot midway and stops working.
Wikus insists Christopher go save
his son and the other prawns.
Christopher promises him that he will be back in
three years, and turn Wikus back to normal.
Wikus distracts the soldiers, as Christopher
takes his son and starts the mother ship.
It rises in the sky and finally
attaches to the spacecraft.
Below, an injured Wikus is arrested by the
Colonel who is about to kill him. However,
the other prawns stand up for Wikus. They circle
the colonel and rip his head off. The massive
spaceship finally takes off with Christopher and
his son in it, as the whole world watches in awe.
People speculate that Christopher will come back
for the rescue mission to save all of his kinds.
Wikus has disappeared completely after the
incident, and no one knows his whereabouts.
The prawn relocating mission was successful.
Currently, they live in District 10,
which lies 200 kilometres outside of Johannesburg
and their population has increased to 2.5 million.
Then, we see footage of Wikus’s wife holding a
metal flower, which she claims she had found at
her doorstep. She believes that Wikus put it there
and still has hopes of him being alive. The movie
ends as we see a now fully transformed Wikus in a
junkyard, crafting a metal rose for his wife.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a like
to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.